ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES WELL
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CHIANG TALLY DAHLE DRAWN SO
GALGIANI. LASER GUNS. GROVE
HERTZBERG HILL WEST TADO JACK'S
JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE NAY.
MONNING MORLOCK MORALE NEIL.
PAN PORTANTINO ROSS RE SKINNER
STERN. NUMBER WHY CASKEY WIENER
WELL. A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LET
IN PER THIS MORNING BY OUR
GUEST CHAPLAIN BUT IT. IN BUT
PLEASE REMAINS THE AS WOULD BE
IN THE PLEDGE OF BY THE JUST
SENATOR FROM THE SILICON VALLEY
CENTERED HILL. GREAT AND LOVING
GOD IN YOUR GOODNESS AND
GENEROSITY WE GATHER ON THE US
SUPREME AND GLORIOUS POWER.
THANK YOU FOR THIS BEAUTIFUL
BLESSED MORNING AS WE COME HERE
TO DO THE OFFICIAL BUSINESS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. LIFE
IS A GIFT TO ALL OF US AND OUR
MOST CHERISHED POSSESSION.
REALIZE THAT IS FRENCH ISLAND
SHORT WITH NO GUARANTEE OF
TOMORROW. HELPERS THEM TO USE
IT WISELY THE TIME YOU GAVE US
EACH DAY TO DO IT THAT. THIS
BUT WE CAN EARN FOR THE
MOUNTAINS OF THE WHO HAVE HERE
TO THE WE ABLE GENTLE SPIRIT OF
GOD. HELP US TO DO IT ONE GOOD
THING TODAY AND SEVEN OF YOUR
PEOPLE. IN OUR VERY BEST STATE.
SHOW HOW TO LIVE A HOLY HUMBLE
GREAT FOR LIVES DOING ALL WEEK
TO THE WERE A PLACE. A NEW GOOD
AND HOLY STE. WE PRAY. YOUR
RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART. AND.
WILL. FOR ALL. THEY YOU LIKE
RIGHT HAVE A HOLLYWOOD JUST.
YOU HE LOOKED THE PART. IT
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SENATE RULE FIFTY WILL SUS TO
ALLOW LOBBY ON THE FLOOR FOR
TODAY SESSION. SEEING NONE WILL
MOVE TO PRIVILEGE AT THE FOR.
SENATOR HER TOP. ARE YOU READY.
NO. IT WILL BE EASY FOR THAT'S
IS GETTING FOR. HER TAUGHT A
MAY PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY O
RECOGNIZE QUARTER. WHO IS A
DISTINGUISHED MEMBER OF THE
RECORDING INDUSTRY'S AND ONE OF
THE FINEST CONTEMPORARY
VOCALIST HE IS KNOWN FOR HIS
WARM BOWLS AND AS A GIFTED
SINGER OF STANDARDS AS WELL AS
MORE CONTEMPORARY SOUL MUSIC.
MORNING WAS. TEEN SEVEN. GREG
PORTED UP IN BAY. HIS WAS A
MENACE AND WHAT HE FOR UNDER
THE SPELL OF NAY KING COLE
WHILE LISTENING TO MOTHER'S
RECORD COLLECTION. HE LEARNED
HOW TO IMITATE IT WOULD GROW TO
BE  GREAT AWARD WINNING
VOCALIST HIMSELF. ALONG WITH
THE SINGING TALENTS HE WAS
GIVEN HE WAS A GIFTED ATHLETE
WHO GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL BOOK
SCHOLARSHIP TO DIEGO STATE YOU.
REPORTER HAS BEEN COMPARED TO
THE- KING COLE DONNY HATHAWAY
AND STAY WONDER. HE ANNOUNCED
HIS ARRIVE BY PICKING UP THE
NOMINATION. UP FOR TWENTY TEN
THE BUTTE WATER. AFTER TO BE
NOTE RECORDS HE GAINED EVEN
WIDER NO FOR A THIRD OUT.
TWENTY THIRTEEN LIQUIDS. HE
GAVE EVEN WIDER NO FOR THIRD.
THE TWO ON THE JAZZ CHARTS ARE
A POLITICS FOR THAT I WANT TO
GRAMMY FOR BEST JAZZ VOCAL
ALBUM ALTHOUGH THIS REGIONAL
SONGS ARE HIS MAIN FOCUS PORTER
OFTEN RETURNS TO ITS ROOTS THAT
SAYS ON HIS TWELVE SEVENTY
TRIBUTE UP BLACK HOLE AND ME.
CAREER RECORD IS MADE A LOT.
TEN ON MILLER OF FANS PARTISAN
IN VERY CHARITABLE PERFORMANCES
BENEFIT CIVIC AND PHILANTHROPIC.
SUCH AS CON AND BASS BAKER TO
HELP INCOME FAMILIES AND HELP
REDUCE POVERTY. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN RECOGNIZING REPORTER FOR THE
MANY YEARS OF LOCAL ENJOYMENT
HE HAS PROVIDED TO CONSTITUENTS
THE SENATE DISTRICT FOURTEEN
COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS AND
AUDIENCES ALL OVER THE WORLD.
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE IT THIS TIME
SENATOR BRADFORD. NO OUR I'M
SORRY SENATE ROBINSON MIKE
THINKING THANK YOU MISTER FOR
IT'S DEFINITELY MY HONOR TO
JOIN MY FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND TO RECOGNIZE A GROUP
QUARTER HERE ON THE FLOOR THEY
ALL OF HIS ACCOUNT YOU KNOW
OPPORTUNITY THESE ARE WHEN YOU
GROW. THREE EVERY SO GRAMMY IN
REACHING OVER TO. MILLION P. IS
A TESTAMENT TO. I'M GRATEFUL
THAT GREG IS A TO SHOW SOUND OF
SOMETHING BETTER WE IS OUR NEW.
AND BAKER SO. AND WHAT YOU'VE
NOT FOR OUR COMMUNITY BUT THE
AND WORLD HE DIDN'T A TEST OF.
ALL MODELS AND- TO MIL. OF THE
KIDS THAT LOOK UP TO YOU EVERY
DAY AND I IS THANK YOU BEING A
OF OUR- AND THINK YOU FOR ALL
YOU DO FILL OF. LEE AND FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU DO TO SURE.
YOU MAKE THE NET GEN BETTER OF
YOU SERVICE TO THEIR LIFE SO
GOOD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
GROW CENTER BROUGH THANK YOU
PRESIDENT I TO RIDE IN A GREAT
REAP ALL MUSIC VOCAL INDIVIDUAL
THAT HIP HOP TO ME THREE YEARS
AGO AT KDL LATEST TO. JEEPERS
WAR TO WORRY A MESMA. BROUGH UP
PLAN. ARE HE WAY THROUGH THE
TENTH GRADE IN A FIVE GOING
SHOPS I HADN'T MAJOR PATCH AS
OF THE GUARDIAN JOBS ALSO GREG.
ONE OF THE- THAT WE HAVE SOUGHT
YOU AFTER OR THE BEFORE. PEOPLE
LIKE YOU SAY- DONNY HATHAWAY
NAT KING COLE WE CAN GO ON AND
ON AND ON EASY A TRUE- CLAIM.
IS THAT IS UNMATCHED AND WE
HAVE ANOTHER OUR COMMON
INTERESTS I TOO AM A LOVE SAID
PEOPLE STATE THAT TOO IS ARE
ARE COMMON GROUND. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A RECOGNIZING GROW BORED
WHEN AND SIXTY FIVE NOMINEES
REPORTER.
OKAY CONTINUING UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
MORALE ARE YOU READY. AT THE AT
THE PRO TEM'S DEATH AND OUR
MORALE. WELL MEMBERS STAFF
MORNING I'M HERE TODAY. ONE OF
MY FAVORITE PEOPLE IN THE WHOLE
WIDE WORLD JESSICA WINNER WHO
CAME TO WORK FOR ME- TEN YEARS
AGO. INTERVIEWED BY FIVE OUT
THREE OR FOUR TIMES AND THEN
WHEN I CAME UP MATTER THE FIRST
TIME SHE LOOKED LIKE SHE WAS
YEARS ALL AN I THOUGHT I WHAT
I DO BUT RATED OVER THE YEARS I.
YOU KNOW POLICY. TRONG A SUIT.
YEAH BUT AS THE- PEOPLE COME IN
THE OFFICE AND DISCUSS POLICY
IT WAS INTERESTING NAY WITH
THEIR EYES WOULD BE ON ME BUT
THEN THEY WOULD FIGURE OUT LARA
QUICK. JESSICA WAS ANY THERE
SO- IT'S BEEN GREAT- I'VE
LEARNED A LOT FROM HER IF
THERE'S MANY TIMES THAT I
THOUGHT SHE WAS THE BOSS- BUT-
I'M SHE'S LEARNED. AND SO IT'S
GONNA BE. REALLY SAD WE GO BUT
ONE OF THE REASON SHE'S
LEAVING. IS SHE'S ACTUALLY TOLD
ME THAT HE WAS HE HAD A HER
SECOND. LILY AND THEN LOW. AND
SHE SAID OUR KIDS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN FOR MIKE ALFA
AND SO. I WONDER THANKS TO THE
BEAT OUR STATE AT HOME MOM AND
WIFE AND MAKE- HER FAMILY.
WHARTON THING IN HER LIFE AND
SO IT'S JUST BEEN A WONDERFUL.
HERE'S A WE HAD TOGETHER AND- I
LOVE HER KIDS AND HER HUSBAND
JOHN OF COURSE YOU GUYS ARE
PROBABLY SEE BROWN SAID THERE
ARE WONDERFUL FAMILY AND WE
TOPPED IT OFF AND A BOWLING
LAST NIGHT TO FIND. AND I'VE
GOT A REST HERE THE- PRISON.
AND SHE WILL BE MASS SPEAK AND
SHE ARE KNOWS MANY P. IN THE-
SHE'S A LIKE THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL BY BOTH SIDES I'LL- AND
IT'LL CERTAINLY BE A BIG. FOR
ME AND I'VE GOT SOME. ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE. BUT ALSO THE
PARENTS ARE HERE MISTER MRS-
AMY AS WELL AS THE- JOHNS DAD
BRAD WINGER SOME HERE SOMEWHERE
HERE. HERSELF AGAIN THANK YOU
GUYS FOR BEING HERE. JESSICA
ARE WE'RE GONNA MISSION.
WELL
CONGRATS CONGRATULATIONS TO
JESSICA AND YOU YOU WILL BE
MISSED IN THE CAPITAL. IN JUNE
WHICH IS OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
BREAUX. ON.
THEIR GROWTH THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IT IS
COLLEAGUES AT GREAT HONOR TO
WELCOME BACK TO THE CHAMBER OUR
FRIEND OUR CALL AGAIN FORMER
STATE SENATOR JEFF STONE NOW
SERVES AS THE US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR. REGIONAL DIRECTOR
OVERSEEING EIGHT STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA AND
ALTHOUGH WE CERTAINLY MISSY YOU
HAVE SITTING NEXT TO ME AND I
KNOW YOUR COLLEAGUE. FROM THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS LIKE A
LITTLE LOST PUPPY HE HE JUST IS
SAD THAT HE DOESN'T GET THE
OPPORTUNITY EVERYBODY SAYS ABBY
LET'S SHOOT MOST OF ALL WE WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
YOU'RE DOING FOR THE EIGHT
STATES THAT YOUR UPPER. AND FOR
YOUR FEARLESS FIGHT FOR TO
SUPPORT FREELANCE ECONOMY
FIGHTING FEARLESSLY IT ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA EIGHT YOUR WORK WITH
THE US DEPARTMENT OF. SO THANK
YOU START. CONTINUING WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND- SENATORS FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY ON PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR I WOULD LIKE T
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT TODAY
RONALD REAGAN'S BIRTHDAY
PURSUANT TO A LEGISLATION THAT
WAS PASSED WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT TEN YEARS AGO AND
SIGNED BY FORMER GOVERNOR.
SCHWARZENEGGER TODAY A HUNDRED
NINE NEVER. PRESIDENT REAGAN.
AS WE ALL KNOW REAGAN
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNOR FOR EIGHT
YEARS AND SERVED AS OUR
NATION'S PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT
YEARS ALSO. HE SADLY PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR AFTER A LONG
BATTLE WITH ALZHEIMER'S I KNOW
THE GOVERNOR NEWSOME ISSUED A
PROCLAMATION REGARDING RONALD
REAGAN DATE LAST YEAR AND I
ANTICIPATE AND HOPE THAT HE
WILL DO SO AGAIN. HERE HI. THE
HOW CAN A PRIEST DROWNED RATE
WAS ONE OF THE GREAT GOVERNOR
OF CAL. I DO A LOT OF GREAT
THINGS FOR OUR STATE I
REMEMBER- ON THE DAY THAT HE
PASSED AWAY IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR. JOURNALING FIVE HI NO
REGARDING HIS PRESIDENCY AND
HAS A- IMPACT ON AMERICA CENTER
EDUCATE. THEM AND SO A JUST I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE RECOGNIZE REMEMBER
RONALD REAGAN ON TODAY ON HIS
BIRTHDAY THANK YOU. IF YOU
SENATOR JOE. MOVING ON-
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
CONVERSATION PLEASE TAKE IT OFF
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M MOVING TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY THIRD
THROUGH THE SIX TO TWENTY
TWENTY WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MOVING ON TO INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS BILLS
ARE DEEMED READ. NOW MOVING ON
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. UP VERSES UNFINISHED
BUSINESS ITEM FOR. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR HER TARA AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE OF THE MEDIA ONLY.
CENTER HER TADO. THE PRESIDENT
I RISE TO PRESENT SB TWO ZERO
SEVEN IS AN ACCESS TO VOTING
BILL THAT WILL REDUCE WAIT
TIMES AT THE POLLS FOR ALL
VOTERS BY STREAMLINED LEAN
STREAMLINING. THE PROCESS FOR
LAST. TO ADDRESS AND PARTY
PREFERENCE THIS BILL ALSO
VOTERS TO UPDATE THEIR ADDRESS
WITHIN THE SPEAK OUT. TO THE
POOL PARTY PREFERENCE TWO WEEKS
PRIOR TO A LOT DAY AS WELL AS
ON. THE IT'S- ON. THE LAVA
SHOULD TAKE THE SIM CHANGE HAVE.
LONG LINES CHECK. OBTAIN A
COMPLETE ARRAY CONFORM AND
PROVISIONAL AND BELOW AND THEN
RECEIVE A PRVISIONAL BALLOT BE
EVEN VOTING. THE SLOW THE
PROCESS DOWN FOR OTHER.
IMPACTING LOOK SELECT ACTUAL
SUSPENDED REESE COUNTING THESE
INCREASED NUMBER PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS SB TWO ZERO SEVEN ONE
SURE SIMPLER FORM IS PROVIDED
TO VOTERS TO PLEAD THE CHANGES
MORE QUICKLY. USING THAT MAY
VOTER NEEDS TO. MARK OR OTHER
OBLIGATIONS AND REDUCING THE
WAIT TIMES ORDERS AT THE POLLS
SB TWO ZERO SEVEN WASAMENDED
TO INCLUDE. THE COST TO ENSURE
THIS BILL IS PASSED. AND
PRESENTED TO THE GOVERNOR
BEFORE THE UPCOMING MARCH
PRIMARY THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
SECRETARY STATES OFFICE AND IS
A NUMBER ONE PRIORITY OF OUR
LOCAL PARKS AND LEX AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS WITH THE
FORTY ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND- SPECIALS AND- PORT. I WAS
ASK. ABOUT. ANY FURTHER DEBATER
DISCUSSION SEEING NONE. I WILL
THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. ATKINS HI
BATES. BELL HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI JANE.
DALLY NO DODD HI THE REST SO HI
GALGIANI HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
FIVE GROVE NO HERTZBERG. HI
HILL HI HUESO HI MURTADA HI
JACKSON HI JONES KNOWS LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI
MONNING HI MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NO NIELSEN. PAN PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN BY NUMBER HI WHY CAN SKI.
HI WIENER HI WILK. CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA BATES NO CHIANG NO
MORE LOCK NO NIELSEN NO HAN.
WILK HI HI. THE URGENCY TWENTY
EIGHTY NINE ON THE URGENCY IN
TWENTY EIGHT TO NINE ON THE
BILL MEASURE. IT MAILLET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIR CONCORD
AND- NOW WE WILL MOVE TO
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. CLERK
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. ONE
FORTY TO ONE FORTY SIX AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY. YEAH MISTER CLARK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. ATKINS HI BATES HI
BEL HI GORGEOUS. HI BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI JANE. HI KELLY HI
DODD HI THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI
HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROWS.
HI HERTZBERG HI HILL HI HUESO
TADO HI JACKSON HI JONES. LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI
MONNING MORE LOCK HIGH MORALE.
HI NIELSEN. PAN BY PORTANTINO.
HI HI RALPH. HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. HI STERN HI I'M BURKE
BY WHY CAL SKI. WIENER BY WILK
HI HI THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN YEAH HI
ARCHULETA. HUESO HI JONES HI
NIELSEN. HI LIKE OWSKI. I.
PRICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
DESPAIR AT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED NOW WE'RE MOVING
WE'RE GONNA RETURN MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS IS AN APPROPRIATE
TIME TO DO A JOURNEY MEMORIES-
NOT APPROACHHIM ARE YOU
PREPARED. AM I AM MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU. IT WAS
REALLY NICE TO- RECOGNIZE A
STAFF MEMBER OF A COLLEAGUE
THAT'S LEAVING. I TODAY AND-
ALONG WITH GOOD NEWS FOR HER
CONGRATULATIONS TO HER AND HER
FAMILY FOR MAKING THAT
DECISION. I ALSO WANT TO SAY
TODAY THAT WERE INCREDIBLY SAD
BECAUSE WE HAVE LOST ANOTHER
INCREDIBLE MANY OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE COMMUNITY. AND THE
COMMUNITY LOST ONE OF OUR MOST
SEASONED TALENTED N. TRYST
INDIVIDUALS. SANDERS BOB NEVER
POSITION THE LEGISLATURE IN A
LONG TEN. AFTER A PETER'S
OFFICE OF MANDY SERVICES WHICH
IS WHERE I GOT TO KNOW HIM.
HAVING WORKED BOB IN THE
ASSEMBLY I WAS AB DELIGHTED
WHENHE CAME OUT OF. TO JOIN
THE SENATE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
WEATHER WAS HOW TO BEST SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR BILLS
WITH OUR COMMUNITY. ARE HELPING
NEW MEMBERS AND EVEN SOME OF US
SEASONED VETERANS AND VETERANS.
WE BECAME MORE COMFORTABLE
SPEAKING TO MEDIA THANKS TO BOB
HE ALWAYS GENEROUSLY SHARED HIS
EXPERTISE. FROM HIS HAIR TO HIS
SUITS. BOB WAS ALWAYS WELL AS
WELL PUT TOGETHER AS EVERY
SENSE HE EVER CRAFTED ON OUR
BEHALF. AS CLAIMED AN
INCREDIBLY PROUD CENTRAL VALLEY
KID BOB ENJOYED A GOOD SCOTCH.
THE LATEST BOOK BY ACE ATKINS
NO RELATION AND THE ROUGH AND
TUMBLE OF A RIGHTEOUS CAMPAIGN.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO BE RAN
SOME OF BOB'S REMINISCENCES
FROM HIS OWN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT PAYING FOR ASSEMBLY. WHEN
HE DOES BEING SUDDENLY CALLED
ON TO GIVE ADVICE. TO SENATOR
ROBERT EIGHTY AS HIS CAMPAIGN
IN WAS TRAVELING PERCENT ALLEY.
CLUTCH MOMENT BOB THROUGH AS HE
ALL DID. THE TWO BOBS SANDERS
AND KENNEDY SHARE TO BELIEVE
THAT GOVERNMENT AND THE
POLITICAL PROCESS MATTERED
MOST. WHEN THEY ARE TOOLS TO
MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES BETTER. SO
MEMBERS I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME
IN RECOGNIZING MY BACK IN
CHAMBER. BOB IS BEAUTIFUL
FAMILY HAVE JOINED US TODAY TO
HONOR BOB WITH US IS HIS LOVING
WIFE SAN DAUGHTER ERICA THERE'S
JEFF TM SISTER IN LAW DEL AND
SUCH. AN IN A BIT INCREDIBLY
MAY HIS. SO WELL AND SO MY AND
PEOPLE WERE THERE TO PAY RISK
TO HIS LIFE I HE WILL BE MISSED
BY FRIENDS COLLEAGUES AND THE
MANY PEOPLE WHO MENTORED ALONG
THE WAY. I AM I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME IN AND TURNING IN MEMORY OF
BOB- SHOULD YOU GET THE CHANCE
AND WE CAN'T DO THAT HERE ON
THE FLOOR BUT I HOPE YOU REYES
CLASS OF SCOTCH IN ALL OF ALL
BOX ART IT HELP WORK TO ENSURE
THIS INSTITUTE THAT HE LOVES SO
MUCH. MAKE LOTS BETTER. YOU
THANK. THANK YOU MATTER PRO TEM.
SENATOR STERN. AT THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
JOIN IN MEMORY OF MY BEST
FRIENDS DAD MARK CHASEN WHO
JUST PASSED AWAY. WE RECENTLY.
HE WAS MY LITTLE LEAGUE COACH.
ED AND SHAPE MY LIFE LIKE. THAT
SO MANY OF US TO. LIVE THAT OUR
FRIENDS HOUSES GROWING UP DO
MADE THEIR OWN IMPRINT ON. OUR
CULTURE GROWING UP IN. MARK WAS
A CHARACTER- HE WAS A SWISS
ARMY KNIFE KINDA GUY. HE
STARTED OUT AT CAL POLY POMONA
STUDY ANIMAL SCIENCE BUT THEN
THE GUY COULDN'T BE A RANCHER
BECAUSE- HE WAS TOO ALLERGIC.
SO HE'S IN SHIFTED OVER I'M I
ACTUALLY DISCOVERED THINGS
ABOUT HIM I HAD NO IDEA MY
STAFF DID THE RESEARCH LET ME
LIST THEM OFF ACCOUNTING-
HONEYDEW MELON FARMING- IT.
SQUARE HONEYDEW MELON FORMING-
BUILT A REAL ESTATE DIGEST-
BECAME A LAW ENFORCEMENT ARM OF
THE IRS WAS A BUDGET ANALYST
FOR THIS THIS YEAR SYSTEM WITH
THIS DIVER. TRAVEL ALL OVER THE
WORLD POSITION- HE'S A
CHARACTER AND IT'S JUST HARD TO
LOSE HIM- WILL LOST HIS MOTHER
WHEN WE WERE GROWING UP TO AND
I ONE ADJOURNMENT MARIE ALSO
TO REMIND US ALL FOR THOSE OF
US WHO HAVE OUR DAD STILL WITH
US THAT- THEY ARE VERY SPECIAL.
ODD CREATURES WHO BECOME THESE
FRIENDS OF OURS LATER IN LIFE
AFTER THEY BECOME SORT OF
DOMINANT FIGURE AND- THEN YOU
HAVE TO TAKE CARE FOR THEM AND
WATCH THEM GET OLD. PASS ON AND
WATCHING WILL STRENGTH THROUGH
THAT PROCESS IS THE LONE SON AN
OPEN KID IN THAT FAMILY- IS
HUGE. SO FOR ALL OF US BEING ON
THERE'S THROUGH THOSE LAST
YEARS IT. AND ESPECIALLY TO.
I'M WILL MISS YOU DEARLY AND
THANK YOU FOR CHAU US A BIT A
WONDER. A BIT OF ECCENTRICITY
AND MOST FALLS IN LOVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR STERN IT AND
SOME SORRY SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS.
SEEING NO OTHER JOURNEY
MEMORIES IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I WILL SEE YOU ALL
MONDAY FEBRUARY TENTH TWO PM.
WE CAN. IT WILL BE RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE WILL RECONVENE BACK
HERE MONDAY AT TWO PM MEMBERS
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.